bonjour et merci d'avoir accepté notre
invitation sur rt france alors
concrètement comment vont se traduire
ses pertes dans le budget de défense de
l'union européenne
le budget de l'union européenne en terme
de défense n'existe pas en tant que tel
il existe en temps uniquement de fonds
d'investissement qui ont été votées
cette année à hauteur de 3 7 milliards
d'euros le budget de la défense de
l'union européenne ne se conçoit pas
comme ça il se conçoit nationalement
donc aujourd'hui si on devait faire le
bilan du départ des grandes et des
britanniques
il faut constater qu'il n'y aura pas de
grands changements en terme de défense
proprement dite et que ce n'est pas le
départ entre guillemets du budget de la
défense britannique qui changera quelque
chose
est-ce que malgré tout on peut imaginer
que ça va être compensées d'une certaine
manière pour retrouver un budget
équivalent à celui de départ à 40
milliards c'est pas comme ça qu'il faut
raisonner
vous avez aujourd'hui entame de défense
de l'union européenne ou de l'europe
deux organismes linsay l'otan et l'autre
effectivement c'est la politique de
défense de l'union européenne
hoti de l'union européenne il n'y a pas
de budget réellement attribuées au titre
de l'otan il ya une contribution par
états au budget de l'otan ce qui reste
majoritaire aujourd'hui c'est les
contributions nationales c'est-à-dire le
budget consacré à la défense par nation
or aujourd'hui qu'est ce qui est
important c'est pas forcément l'argent
qui est donné c'est ce qu'on va en faire
or si on devait parler peut-être de
l'implication britannique les
britanniques c'est l'une des deux armées
principal en europe en termes
d'efficacité avec la france aujourd'hui
la coopération se fait entre les
français et les britanniques notamment
dans la conception d'un corps
expéditionnaire depuis dix ans on fête
cette année les dix ans de lancaster
house qui fait qu est une force franco
britannique expéditionnaire qui se monte
à des après année avec sebring dit et ce
qu'on peut imaginer un projet concret de
défense européenne qui serait comme vous
en parliez complémentaire à l'otan oui
tout à fait puisque c'est quand même
l'un des objectifs du président macron
que l'europe l'union européenne soit
souveraine au type de sa défense un
deuxième facteur est important à prendre
en compte en compte ce n'est pas
tellement le départ des britanniques
mais c'est surtout le changement de
politique des états unis avec l'arrivée
de joe biden joe biden va modifier en
principe nous fait tout le monde espère
l'avenir des relations entre l'europe et
les états unis
ça ne veut pas dire que les états unis
vont payer plus mais dans tous les cas
l'exemple de trump pendant quatre ans a
montré que l'europe devait être
souveraine en terme de défense et un
certain nombre de gouvernements
européens ont bien pris conscience qu'il
fallait que cette défense soient
européennes principalement quelle est la
prochaine étape pour le royaume uni est
ce qu'on peut penser par exemple que
boris johnson chercherait d'autres aux
alliés ou pas fin novembre 2020 le
premier ministre annonce est la plus
importante augmentation
budget britannique de la défense depuis
30 ans alors il est dit houle est écrit
qu'il pourrait y avoir d'aidé
coopération notamment dans le domaine de
l'armement en termes de production
d'armement donc nous sommes bien dans
l'économie et dans l'industrie de
défense qui est un peu différent en
terme de sécurité proprement dit
le discours de ben jonson aujourd'hui
c'est de dire la grande bretagne est
souveraine
je suis capable seule d'assurer ma
défense ce qui est pas tout à fait exact
même si c'est une île cependant il faut
constater que depuis de nombreuses
années les forces armées britanniques
ont subi de forte déflation une forte
baisse de leurs capacités de projection
et qu'aujourd'hui ce n'est pas des
annonces budgétaires tels que font le
favori johnson qui vont changer grand
chose pour l'instant les britanniques ne
sont pas vraiment en mesure de peser sur
la défense général ils ne peuvent que se
consacrer à la défense de leurs propres
il donc aujourd'hui les déclarations
politiques je pense qu'il faut les
regarder avec précaution surtout dans le
contexte économique général que tout le
monde connaît aujourd'hui
merci beaucoup pour tout ces précisions
françois chavance y est je le rappelle
que vous êtes général de brigade et
expert en géostratégie merci à vous